we're given a system of equations here
and we're told to solve for x and y now
the easiest thing to do here since in
both equations they're explicitly solved
for y and say well if Y is equal to that
and Y also has to equal this second
equation then why don't we just set them
equal to each other or another way to
think about it is if Y is equal to this
whole thing right over here that's what
that first equation is telling us and if
we have to find an x and y that satisfy
both of these equations if y is equal to
that Y I can I just substitute that
right here for Y and if we do that this
the left-hand side of this bottom
equation becomes negative 1/4 X plus 100
and then that is going to be equal to
this right hand side I'll do it in the
same color is equal to negative 1/4 X
plus 120 now the first thing we might
want to do is maybe get all of our X
terms on to the left or the right hand
side of the equation and if we wanted to
get rid of these X terms from the right
hand side get them on the left hand side
the best thing to do is to add 1/4 X to
both sides of this equation so let me do
that so we're going to add 1/4 X here
add 1/4 X here and you might already be
sensing that something shady is going on
so let's do it
so negative 1/4 X plus 1/4 X they cancel
out you get 0 X so the left side of the
equation is just to 100 and then the
right side of the equation
same thing negative 1/4 X plus 1/4 X
they cancel out no X is and you're just
left with is equal to 120 which we know
cannot that is definitely not the case
100 is not equal to 120 we got this
nonsensical equation here that 100
equals 120 so this type of system has no
solution it has no solution and you know
it has no solution because in order for
it to have any solution these two
numbers would have to be equal to each
other and they are not equal to each
other and if you look at the original
equations it might jump out at you why
they have no solutions both of these
means or both of these equations if you
view them as lines have the exact same
slope they have the exact same slope but
they have different y-intercepts so if I
just were to do a really quick graph
here if I were to do a really quick
graph here that's my y-axis that is my
x-axis it's Y and X this first graph
over here it's y-intercept is 100 its
y-intercept is let me do it a little bit
lower its y-intercept let's say that
that is 100 so it intersects right there
and it's the slope of negative 1/4 so
maybe it looks something like this maybe
it looks something like that that's that
first line this second line I'll do it
in pink right here Y is equal to
negative 1/4 X plus 120 its y-intercept
might be right here at 120 but it has
the same slope negative 1/4 so it's
slope it's the line would look something
like this so you see that there are no
X&Y points that satisfy both of these
equations another way to think about it
if y is you take an X this first
equation says ok you take your X
multiply it by negative 1/4 and add 100
and that's going to give you Y now here
we say well you take that same X and you
multiply it by negative 1/4 and add 120
and that has to be equal to Y well the
only way that that would ever be true is
if 100-120 we're the same number and
they're not the same number so you're
never going to have a solution of this
system these two lines are never going
to intersect and that's because they
have the exact same slope